welcome to the class day ceremony
celebrating the accomplishments of the
class of 2010
we are very pleased to have one of our
graduating seniors miss Lena Park sing
the national anthem a native Californian
Lena has spent her adult life in South
Korea where she is one of the most
popular recording artists with eight
solo albums released in Korea three
albums plus six singles in Japan and
release of her work in China Taiwan
Singapore and Malaysia Lena graduates
with a degree in English and comparative
literature magna laude Phi Beta
Kappa and a member of the GS Honor
Society please rise for the national
anthem
oh say can you see by the dawn's early
light what so proudly we hailed at the
twilight's last gleaming whose broad
stripes and bright stars through the
perilous fight all the ramparts we
watched were so gallantly streaming the
bombs bursting gay proof through the
night that our flag was still there oh
say does that star-spangled banner yet
wave
on the left
and the free
Oh
I'm especially pleased that President
Lee Bollinger Provost Claude Steele
executive vice president Nicholas Dirk's
and members of the faculty and
administration are here to share in our
celebration I would also like to welcome
our class day speaker mr. Jacques Tappan
class of 1970 finally it is my privilege
to welcome our reunion classes and an
especially warm welcome goes to mr.
Larry Lawrence GS 69 Business School 71
Larry is a tireless advocate for G s
students and alumni this year he is one
of the recipients of the University
Alumni Medal which will be awarded the
morning of commencement the Faculty of
Columbia University is committed to the
idea that an Ivy League education should
be available to talented women and men
at any point in their lives whether our
students are dancers entrepreneurs or
fighter fighters military veterans or
Wall Street bankers whether they are in
the challenging joint program with
lists' College of the Jewish Theological
Simmons
at leats whether they are international
students or new Americans they received
the same superb education as all
Columbia graduates a little-known fact
is that the vast majority of students in
two and four-year colleges around the
country look more like gyah students
than students who attend college right
out of high school yet GS remains the
only College at an Ivy League university
that fully mainstream's into the
undergraduate program students who have
taken a very different path to complete
a
and traditional undergraduate degree GS
students and you especially our
graduates this year represent the
cutting edge of American undergraduate
education and you have proven yourselves
through your academic accomplishments
since he assumed the presidency of
Columbia in 2002 Lee Bollinger has
articulated a dynamic vision for the
future of this great University
and mobilized the human and financial
resources required to transform that
vision into reality in the past eight
years president Bollinger has skillfully
guided to completion the approval
process for Columbia's ambitious
expansion into Manhattanville in West
Harlem he continues to enhance
scientific research epitomized by the
current construction of a major Center
for Neuroscience the first new building
in Manhattan Ville president Bollinger
has also moved Columbia into the
forefront of international universities
with the establishment of Columbia
centers in Beijing China Amman Jordan
Mumbai India and Paris with additional
centers planned for Africa South America
and other parts of the world he has
focused the university's priorities on
improving even further the undergraduate
program Columbia remains one of the
world leaders in undergraduate education
because of its creativity breadth and
sophistication of its program and the
superb quality of its faculty president
Bollinger is also a committed educator
continuing to teach an undergraduate
course on the First Amendment even while
he leads Columbia University it is my
privilege to introduce to you the 19th
president of Columbia University Lee
see Bollinger
thank you very much Peter and we all
know we're incredibly fortunate to have
you as Dean and please join me in
thanking Dean on
I just want to open my saying that I
wish I could sing the way that indeed I
I wish I could sing at all so it's a
pleasure to be here I am a great fan of
Jacques Pepin and look forward to
hearing him he strikes me as the perfect
example of being able to engage in high
creativity and being extremely relaxed
while doing so I always try to imitate
that relaxation when I'm cooking since
I'm going to have my turn at the podium
on Tuesday at commencement I'm just
going to take a moment to welcome you
today and of course all the families the
spouses the children and friends of the
Graduate I also want to recognize Larry
Lawrence and his wife Sally and also for
their incredible generosity to general
studies Columbia University has long
been committed to the values of access
and diversity in higher education and no
where can you find as great an example
of this basic principle than right here
in the extraordinary breadth and
accomplishments of students that sit
before you today you are world-class
dancers athletes musicians small
business owners who join us from 35
States and over 20 countries from as far
away as China Israel and Germany you
came to us when you were 17 years old or
maybe 65 and of course many of you are
military veterans General Studies is
proud as is Columbia to graduate ten
military veterans in the class of 2010
four of whom
four of whom are joining us through
Columbia's participation in the Yellow
Ribbon Program an initiative of the post
9/11 GI Bill as dean on often points out
the school of general studies was
founded in large part to meet the needs
of GIS returning from World War two so
it is only fitting that we carry on that
tradition today and proudly welcomed the
largest population of undergraduate
former soldiers sailors airmen and
Marines in the Ivy League
each member of the class of 2010 came to
us through their own unique
circumstances you are first-generation
college students transfer students and
professionals from across the United
States and across the globe some of you
even returned to complete second degrees
in new disciplines you are the founding
members of the Columbia Ballet
collaborative all professional dancers
who overcame the challenges of finding
opportunities to perform in New York
City by establishing a group repeatedly
praised and profiled by the New York
Times for its contribution to promoting
new choreography your contributions in
the classroom and creativity on the
stage are remarkable you are a student
in the federally funded global Scholars
Program who overcame addiction and a
troubled life on the streets of northern
Manhattan to earn his GED and today
graduates with honors next fall he will
enter Columbia's School of International
and public affairs in pursuit of his
master's in urban and social policy
you are a member of the elite Green
Berets who lobbied on behalf of his
fellow veterans in Washington for the
implementation of the post 9/11 GI bill
today he is one of the first students
receiving yellow ribbon benefits to
graduate from Columbia and next fall he
will attend the London School of
Economics and you are a successful
stockbroker who at age 50 had run the
New York City Marathon but had not yet
achieved his dream of earning a college
degree seven years later after studying
English and comparative literature
part-time he is now a college graduate
all of your fascinating and wonderful
paths have converged here on this day at
this moment to unite you all as Columbia
graduates we know this is not
necessarily been an easy path all the
more reason for me to say how proud we
are of what you've achieved and that
you've made Columbia an essential part
of the next step in life congratulations
to all of you and I look forward to
seeing you on Tuesday as you join
together with all 12,000 members of the
Columbia class
I am privileged to introduce our class
day speaker Jacques Pepin renowned chef
author businessman television
personality and Columbia alumnus Jacques
has been involved in the culinary world
since his adolescence in 1959 after
having served as personal chef to the
then French president general chef de
Gaulle he immigrated to the United
States 48 48 hours after arriving in New
York he came to the Columbia campus and
enrolled in Columbia's renowned English
as a second language program Jacques
turned down the offer by the Kennedys to
be White House chef and stayed in New
York to continue his education at gs
while holding a major position in
research and development for the Howard
Johnson restaurant chain of over 600
restaurants as an undergraduate Jacques
excelled majoring in French and writing
a senior honors thesis on Moliere on
graduating from GS he was accepted into
the m.a ph.d program in French at
Columbia's Graduate School of Arts and
Sciences here too he demonstrated his
intellectual gifts completing his
master's degree and his coursework for
the PhD when it came time to present a
topic for his doctoral dissertation
Jacques proposed an in-depth study of
food in French literature but this was
the 1970s and Jacques as usual was ahead
of his time
he was told by his faculty mentors that
food was too trivial for academic study
ironically today innumerable books are
written on food and culture and the
study of food is a well-regarded
academic enterprise since Columbia
jacque's career has been legendary he
continues his academic pursuits through
his writing and teaching he is dean of
special approach special programs at the
French Culinary Institute here in New
York and was instrumental in the
creation of the Masters in gastronomy
program at Boston University where he
also teaches he is the recipient of
three of the French government's highest
honors and was honoured by gs during our
50th anniversary celebration in 1997 it
is a true pleasure to introduce to you
consummate artists an alumnus
extraordinaire Jacques Pepin
well thank you thank you so much
good morning and thank you again
professor on for you
yo Dean and my friend congratulation to
you Peter on your achievement at the
Dean of general city for so many years
and thank you for inviting me and for
that glowing and traduction Thank You
president Bollinger vice president Dirk
and Kurtis Roger who coordinated my
visit I'm more than delighted I'm unable
to believe that I'm here in for review
today but especially congratulations to
all of you graduate this is an
extraordinary achievement and I'm really
honored to share this day with you when
I graduated from General City on June 2
1970 the Dean of general three what
Aaron Warner I would never have thought
that 40 years or so later I would be
here giving the commencement address
this is a surprise and a great honor I'm
here today as your speaker to inspire
you I'm not sure that I can do it but I
will try I came to the United State on a
student boat traveling from Louisville
in France to Quebec City and then one
went on by train from Quebec to New York
City Grand Central Station
it was 1959 I was 23 years old I'd left
my country and came here at an immigrant
ready to conquer the world and what
already a chef at the time we've been
work for 10 years in some of France best
restaurant in Paris and in my family
restaurant around Lyon and to all of
those year I had remained a chef on that
ship in the fall of 1959
there were 1,200 American student coming
back from summer vacation and study in
Europe and it took 10 days to sell from
North America I befriended a free
student on the ship but it was difficult
could I spoke very little English at the
time nevertheless I spoke I met a man
who spoke enough French so that we could
converse and I asked him what the best
school in New York was without
hesitation he said Columbia
University I arrived in New York on the
10th of September began working at a
famous French restaurant called the
pavilion on the 12 and then roll the
following week here to study English for
foreign student I had to learn how to
study again because I had left school at
13 after primary school to begin my
cooking apprenticeship from September 59
until July 1972 I study every term at
Columbia and except for my final two
years when I was in the Graduate School
of art and science spent most of that
time in general study after the
non-credit English language study I went
into a validation program and eventually
will accept it in a regular Bachelor of
the great program and ultimately
completed Graduate Studies
it took years and it was the greatest
time of my life I'm still amazed at my
luck in my mid-20s with only a primary
school education to be accepted at
Columbia University was nothing short of
miraculous I believe it could not have
happen in any other country and it could
not have happened in any other schools
and general study I certainly want to
thank some of my many professor at the
time in general sorry for those years to
give their knowledge and their passion
and to tutored me and advised me by
trying to professor Cheatham a professor
fellow professor Edelman professor frame
professor sorry professor Riveter among
many others I believe I did well in most
of my subject except maybe in phonetics
as you can clearly hear so general study
add and select the greatest rattle
national student body at least 25
percent you had to be motivated to study
here most people pay for the study as I
did about the typical non-traditional
student and owl which represented the
night student in general study most of
my fellow classmates are pursued their
education for years had no college
background or like me never even had a
secondary education most could only
study part-time because of work family
commitment or military duty
at this time in general sorry the
English class for foreign students were
attended by a fair amount of people from
Spanish Asian and Eastern European bloc
country the student body was vibrant
enthusiastic curious and demanding in
many ways there was no age limit no
class system no sham of a lowly
background or lack of education I
remember working the University campus
over and over
it became my hangout to think a place of
meditation a place for meeting with
friend or just looking at life going by
it was my comfort zone long before I
came somewhat articulate in English in
America we are lucky to have the
possibility of an education at any age
without being penalized looked down lost
at or ridiculed there is no limit if you
have ambition like many of you I pay for
my education by working during the day
and studying at night I like the
restaurant business world but I had
somewhat of a complex about not having
much of a formal education I wanted a
dreamed of becoming educated or teaching
or writing I also remember amazing
discussion at the cafeteria across
campus on Broadway with five six eight
classmates from different part of the
world all with bad english all full of
hope all excited and happy to be in
America where everything was possible to
us truly America and I had a vision it I
eventually moved into the Graduate
School with my heart and youthful
excitement remain a general study during
the year that I took clubs there the
debates with my fellow student on
subject ranging from politics to art we
are good for improving our English the
students were engaged and it was
exhilarating we shared an invigorating
feeling that I've never found again and
I proceeded with my education elsewhere
but it turned out my professional life
did not judgments throughout the
following years but it was considerably
enhanced by my liberal arts study I was
still a chef but a different level than
before I started writing articles books
and eventually worked on television
none of these would have happened if I
had not gone to general study my life
was totally change and bettered we could
have those years of studies at almost 75
years of age I am still a chef and also
the chef at climbed up the social ladder
at that time it was considered a
relatively lowly and uninspired job
getting an education preventing me from
having a complex about not having an
education I was now a proud college
graduate and the job I was doing I did
it by choice because I wanted to and I
felt good about about myself we could
have married ocation at the school of
general sorry sky was the limit today
you have your degree and it is the
beginning of your career the beginning
of your life it is a time of hope a time
to believe in yourself
a time to dare it is a time when the
world impossible does not exist in your
vocabulary a time to reach for the sky
remember that you are the want to create
opportunities for yourself in life
you're responsible for your happiness I
have the courage to try fortune smiles
on the audacious
you have a long road in front of you but
it is a good road a happier road on this
special day the world is yours world and
the future is your future to shape the
degree that you are getting today it
with you for the rest of your life it is
a testament to your accomplishment it is
much more than a certificate and it will
remain in your mind and in your heart
forever
the knowledge that you have acquired
here is a knowledge that you would
passed on to your children and your
children's children because the
education that you have completed a
general theory is unique however with
that recognition come also
responsibilities responsibilities to
become engaged in society to change
things for the better and to leave a
mark same time to reflect on your life
in the last few years take time to enjoy
your lives now life itself is the reward
the benchmark the recompense sometimes
we are so intent in looking forward that
we forgot the
not moment don't make that mistake look
forward branch over here and now learn
in time of hardship when life become
difficult but it's usually done at some
point think of this moment no one can
take this moment away from you
this is yours and yours alone an
accomplishment to be proud of an
achievement that will convert you in
darker days remember that success in
life is very simple and very complex
success in life is to be happy with
yourself with what you are with what you
do if you love what you do you know you
never have to go to work Monday for the
sake of money doesn't make a person
happy although it may contribute to a
fair amount don't forget the simple
pleasure of life for me it is still a
sharing a meal or a bottle of wine with
friend the enjoyment of being together
with family in front to share this is
true happiness I've been blessed with a
wonderful wife for over 43 years a great
daughter and a carrier that I have
enjoyed for more than 60 years again the
greatest advice I can give you is to do
what you love I've been asked as a chef
how does your general degree you general
study degree help where does it fit into
your life I firmly believe that without
it I would never have had the carrier as
complete and as successful as I did the
story of liberal art literature
philosophy open your mind and it makes
me a more complete person that I would
be otherwise I would have been a
complete without it at a graduate of
general study you are important your
education enables you to influence to
affect and to touch the people around
you from your family to your frown and
beyond I believe in the goodness of
human nature with some people and at
some time it does seem not to be too
apparent with the good net is there with
some digging it appears and it is well
worth the effort to reveal it don't
forget that now with your education you
can analyze you can understand you can
be open tolerant this is what a liberal
education does for you with the
education that I got here at GS
I can truly say that the sky has been
the limit an education is important to
quote Gilbert Shuster town an English
writer of the last century without an
education you are in the Honorable and
deadly danger of taking educated people
seriously this should not happen to you
you know you should be able to reflect
on your life and laugh at yourself
occasionally don't take yourself too
seriously finally I want to thank you
for the wonderful honor of addressing
you today I wish I could start my study
right here all over again congratulation
and have a great life
both the salutatorian and valedictorian
this year represent the very best of the
GS Columbia tradition our salutatorian
miss Isis Paloma was born in Havana Cuba
in 1992 her family emigrated to the US
as political refugees living in New
Jersey in Florida the family adapted to
life in the US and Isis proved herself a
brilliant student after a semester at
Yale
Isis decided to take time off from her
education when she returned to school at
Columbia she pursued her passion for
classical Latin literature and the
ancient Near East studying both Akkadian
and middle Egyptian throughout her
Columbia career she remained engaged
with the surrounding community
especially by tutoring second graders
through America Reads Isis graduates
with honors and classics and a average
summa laude Phi Beta Kappa and a
member of the GS Honor Society please
join me in congratulating the GS
salutatorian for 2010 Miss Isis Paloma
Brian Corman valedictorian of the class
of 2010 was born in Fairfax Virginia at
the age of 11 Brian started taking dance
classes and soon joined the Kirov
Academy of ballet in Washington after
one semester at Berkeley Brian left
school to join the Houston Ballet from
Houston he went to Hubbard Street Dance
of Chicago the Washington Ballet and
Cedar Lake dance company here in New
York while at the Washington Ballet
Bryan danced numerous leading roles and
world premieres he also spearheaded and
was a lead negotiator in the effort by
the Washington Ballet dancers to join
the guild of musical artists Union
coordinator for Amnesty International
and as an intern for congressman Charles
Rangel he is also senior class president
and head of the senior gift committee in
his application to G s Bryan wrote the
leading inspiration in my life has
always been my father the late
California Congressman James C Korman a
true statesman and humanist who showed
me through his work as a lawyer
and congressman the potential of a mind
dedicated to changing the world I hope
one day to become the man I saw in him
Bryan graduates with better than an
a-average honors in political science
summa laude Phi Beta Kappa member of
the GS Honor Society winner of the Ross
prize and the Phi Beta Kappa prize but
if you ask Bryan what is his greatest
accomplishment without hesitation he
would tell you
that it is marrying last Sunday the love
of his life
Katie Barclay corpsman
after graduation Brian will be attending
law school at UC Berkeley
Brian Corp president Bollinger executive
vice president Dirk's provost Ile Dean
on faculty Dean's friends and fellow
graduates I am honored to be a part of
the GS class of 2010 it's true that we
may not have entered Columbia at the
same time spend four years together as
one class or live together in the same
dorm room our freshman year all those
things typical of an undergraduate class
in fact this is the first time this
class has ever been together in the same
place at the same time but it's what
makes us different and unique that makes
us great over the years I've gotten to
know many of you and I can tell you that
this has got to be the most distinctive
and extraordinary group of seniors
imaginable we've received military
honors and Olympic medals have founded
and managed companies worked in top
modeling agencies written books and
designed buildings while we may not have
grown up here together we all share
three important things determination
experience and diversity
skipped a page when it comes to
determination I can tell you right now
that none of us took an easy road to get
here today and in fact we all chose to
take the hard road the one less traveled
which is exactly why we ended up here
and why this class is so incredible who
could possibly say that the military
veterans here today did not take a hard
road to get here they fought to defend
our country in Iraq and Afghanistan and
some like Jose Robledo are in the ROTC
program and are returning to active duty
and likewise who could say that the many
parents here such as Evan and Cathy
Madeo Sarah Bess or Sabrina Ventura who
have somehow been able to balance
college and raising amazing children
took the easy road there's one
particular person whom I want to point
out and that's Tim Goble the quad king
tim is the only figure skater to have
ever done three quadruple jumps in
competition a feat he accomplished at
the US Nationals in 2000 which you can
see on YouTube for yourself but what
made it truly extraordinary was that in
this particular program Tim was supposed
to do a triple followed by three
quadruples not 15 seconds into the
program Tim goes into that first triple
and he falls flat on his face
I mean he just eats it you even hear the
commentators say that there's absolutely
no way he's gonna try even one quad it's
just too risky and then he gets up and
does a perfect quad and another and
another and does what no figure skater
has ever been able to do before or since
two years later Tim went to Salt Lake
City where he earned an Olympic medal
and in a few minutes he'll receive his
degree in mathematics and believe it or
not despite the odds he even has a job
waiting for him when he graduates
but it's this company but it's this kind
of determination that's the embodiment
of our class as a whole to defy the odds
and the naysayers and to achieve the
improbable the second grade attributed
is class is its experience our multitude
of experiences is why over the years
we've gotten a bit of a bad rap in the
classroom a rumor about GS has gone
around that we're always the first ones
to raise our hands to question the
professor or to prove to everybody that
were right and I'm here to set the
record straight this rumor is absolutely
true at the same time when most people
don't talk about is that this can
actually be a great thing during my
second year I took a class called
physics for poets for those of you who
don't know about this class it's
basically a science class for
non-science majors but in this
particular semester the class was taught
by the head of the physics department
and it was obvious that this was not his
favorite place to be at nine o'clock in
the morning twice a week but for some
reason for the final exam
I guess he decided he was going to try
to reach out and connect with us so he
gave us a series of five word problems
and one of the problems as written said
Captain Kirk is sitting on the bridge of
the USS Enterprise when a Klingon ship
attacks
he tells Spock to fire the phasers if
the phasers are leaving the phaser tube
going this fast and the Klingon ship is
going this fast it's basically a
distance and velocity problem in space
we're all sitting in the very back of
this big auditorium and in the middle of
the exam
Paul Grossman gets up walks all the way
down to the front of the lecture hall
and he gets really close to the
professor and he's telling him something
very direct and very pointed and very
specific to him and then he turns and
walks away
and the professor's head drops his
shoulders slump forward he slowly gets
up and says if I could have your
attention please I'm very sorry
I've just been informed that Sulu fires
the phasers on the USS Enterprise this
makes this problem impossible to solve
give your blue books to your teaching
assistants and we'll deal with it
accordingly
and finally diversity now I've already
talked about the uniqueness and
independence of this class so I'll just
briefly tell you about the moment I
realized how important GS was to me in a
class on race in American politics we
watched a video of president Bollinger
talk about his defense of affirmative
action in a Supreme Court case he argued
that a diverse environment enhances the
educational experience of all students
he explained that everybody recognizes
Shakespeare as an essential element to a
good education and that's because
Shakespeare had an unbelievable genius
in being able to cross into the
sensibilities of his characters and it's
a rare capacity one that everyone seeks
in every field and I'll stop
paraphrasing him at this point he is
after all sitting right behind me he
said we all try and it's very hard to do
to get out of our own minds and to see
the world as other people see it it's
fundamentally true about our natures and
about what it means to do things like no
literature or do anthropology or do law
or medicine seeing the world as other
people see it is a critical part of
being an educated person it is just as
critical to an education as the study of
Shakespeare not half an hour later I was
sitting in the GS section of literature
humanities Lit hum is one of the
signature classes in
core curriculum we were reading of all
things
King Lear I looked around the room I saw
former firemen and a ballerina a Marine
an Army Ranger a Nigerian a Colombian
and two Israelis we ranged in age from
24 to 40
heis then that my education hadn't come
from Homer Thucydides or servantes I
could have read all these books at home
my education what I've really learned
has come from all of you I've come to
know some of the most brilliant and
daring people I could ever hope to meet
and they've helped shape Who I am as a
student and as a human being it's always
cliche to talk about the potential of a
graduating class but I know without a
doubt that there is nothing we can't
achieve and the reason I can say this
without falling into hyperbole is that
there's hardly anything this class
hasn't already done I'm humbled before
this group not only for what it has done
but also for what it is surely going to
achieve and there are many problems that
we face we're confronting the biggest
economic and social challenges this
country has seen in decades but it's in
times like these that we absolutely
should not be doing the same old things
in the same old ways which is exactly
where we come in if any group notice how
to deal with these adversities in new
and unique ways it's this one some
people may think of a degree from
Columbia as a ticket to the good life I
think there are many more of us here
today who think of it as a ticket to
change the world
and although I've gone on about our
individuality and independence none of
us would be here were it not for our
families and friends for whom we should
all be eternally thankful
and we are equally grateful to the
faculty and advisers whose guidance and
support has made this possible if I can
be so bold as to give one last piece of
advice it's that we always remember that
we the GS class of 2010 were never
victims of destiny we were always
willing out of a sense of adventure
opportunity defiance or passion to
create our own unique stories and now
that we've spent some years in the
classroom still let us not forget that
sense of adventure that independence and
all those qualities that made us GS
students in the first place this has
been the best four years of my life and
I'm honored to be a part of the GS class
of 2010 thank you
each year the Alumni key is bestowed on
a senior who has achieved distinction
academically and through service to the
school Larry Lawrence class of 69 will
present the award the choice this year
was particularly difficult since so many
graduating seniors have distinguished
themselves both as scholars and members
of the Columbia community I am
particularly grateful to the members of
the GS student council and to the GS
senior gift committee who have raised
over $3,500 which will be matched by a
generous pledge from one of our
graduating seniors Paul Zachary this
year the Alumni key is awarded to
Katherine Edwards before coming to GS
Katherine Edwards studied classical
singing at the Manhattan School of Music
she has performed at venues in Europe
and around the United States at Columbia
Katherine majored in economics and will
graduate magna laude in addition to
her academic achievements Katherine has
worked tirelessly on behalf of gs
students as a member of the student
council and then as its president during
the current academic year her engaging
leadership style and her collaborative
approach to working with the ax cambia
administration have won her the
admiration of her peers and the GS
Dean's after graduation Katherine will
join the compensation consulting firm
variant advisors here in New York join
me in congratulating Katherine Edwards
alumni key Award recipient for 2010
good morning my name is Scott Hall
verson and I am the dean of students of
the school of general studies
president Bollinger Provost Steele
executive vice president Dirk's Dean on
mr. pappan distinguished faculty
dedicated alumni assembled guests it is
my privilege and my very great pleasure
to present to you one by extraordinary
one our candidates for Bachelor of Arts
and Bachelor of Science in the school of
general studies class of 2010 each
degree candidate will receive a
certificate of achievement from
president Bollinger with this special
moment captured on film by our
photographer dr. Adam Kasdan Class of 95
will then present each graduate with the
GS alumni pin at this moment in the
program the person standing here is
compelled to make the most difficult
request of the year but I ask that you
please hold your applause until all the
graduates have been formally presented
on stage for the simple reason that we
would not wish to have one family's
exuberance drown out the presentation of
another proud family's graduate I
promise you ample time for unbridled
jubilation when the presentation of the
class of 2010 is concluded thank you so
much for your understanding
and restraint with a few exceptions here
and there this year's class will be
presented in reverse alphabetical order
approximately
with the candidates for the degrees of
Bachelor of Arts and Bachelor of Science
draw near Lina Hyun Park Bachelor of
Arts English magna laude katherine
Jordan Edwards Bachelor of Arts
economics magna laude
Sydney Lauren stutter hime Bachelor of
Arts art history summa laude Phi
Beta Kappa Fabien Rashard Bachelor of
Arts economics Paul Zachary Bachelor of
Arts political science magna laude
Alice yuan Bachelor of Arts religion
Adina tunnel you'll cut bachelor of arts
history Onika Shabazz Bachelor of Arts
psychology Robert F Clements bachelor of
arts architecture laude sarah Wu Chi
Nick Bachelor of Arts creative writing
with a concentration in history Raul
Javier che wiggling Bachelor of Arts
political science Kathryn Taylor Wiker
bachelor of science neuroscience and
behavior
Priscilla Elaine white Bachelor of Arts
biological sciences laude
Russell Earl Whitaker Bachelor of
Science biochemistry Bhatia gross
Weinstock Bachelor of Arts visual arts
laude
Thomas Anthony Williams Bachelor of Arts
film studies in psychology laude
Sabrina Ventura Bachelor of Arts
anthropology kwan/wong batch
arts history magna laude rebecca
Lillian Walker Bachelor of Arts religion
Lydia Rose Walker Bachelor of Arts
history
magna laude Phi Beta Kappa Marta
wolinski Llanes Bachelor of Arts
sociology laude a Virginia meriva
Lottie Bachelor of Arts art history
magna laude
Federica Vegas Bachelor of Arts
political science
Theodore Stanger Utley Bachelor of Arts
film studies concentration in Portuguese
magna laude jasja vl2 er Bachelor of
Arts biological sciences
Justin Paul ternasky Bachelor of Arts
political science magna laude a
JSONP trig staad Bachelor of Arts
economics Stephen Rory Tobias Bachelor
of Arts English Amy Murray tikkun or
Bachelor of Arts anthropology Samuel
Thomas Bachelor of Science environmental
biology magna laude Kay Wheaton
Bachelor of Arts economics summa
laude a Phi Beta Kappa
cerimon de Nell Swaggart Bachelor of
Arts English magna laude Vanya
radonjic Bachelor of Arts psychology
magna laude joseph gerard tan
Bachelor of Arts neuroscience and
behavior concentration and philosophy to
mow a cigarette
sue Europe Bachelor of Arts music
Leia and Stine bachelor of science
neuroscience and behavior Bianca
Katarina's Talib Bachelor of Arts
economics philosophy Emilia June Spooner
Bachelor of Arts anthropology in history
summa laude Phi Beta Kappa
Christopher how Kalani's pizanno
Bachelor of Arts sociology concentration
in political science
Alijah Kinch Spector Bachelor of Arts
creative writing
Nicholas Matthew sordin Bachelor of Arts
economics Jordan Andrew Smith Bachelor
of Arts art history Chloe Smith Bachelor
of Arts history
summa laude Phi Beta Kappa Abe
Skolnick bachelor of science computer
science
Erica Michelle Sklar Bachelor of Arts
creative writing magna laude
Beth skip Bachelor of Arts Women's
Studies laude joseph william sista
bachelor of science chemistry young park
bachelor of arts asian-american studies
and economics Alicia and Simpson
Bachelor of Arts sociology laude
jessica rose Silverman Bachelor of Arts
Middle East and Asian languages and
culture ashley elizabeth silber
Bachelor of Arts women's studies Kate
Caitlin faith Sigler Bachelor of Arts
film studies show Kaitaia Shephard
Bachelor of Arts archaeology Hannah
Racine Shaw Bachelor of Arts art history
and history laude jacob lewis
shapiro bachelor of arts history magna
laude
Benjamin Michael Shapiro Bachelor of
Arts philosophy
Marla and Schwartz Bachelor of Arts
mathematics Ekaterina Scofield Bachelor
of Arts economics concentration in
mathematics and Russian languages and
cultures Dominic Samuels Cullotta
Scaletta Bachelor of Arts mathematics
and physics Tali sir rig bachelor of
science neuroscience and behavior magna
laude Phi Beta Kappa
Marianne Katherine Santoro Bachelor of
Arts German literature and cultural
history
Daniel Scholl Sachs Bachelor of Arts
biological sciences Lula yme omikoshi
Bachelor of Arts biological sciences
Emily Sheila Musso Bachelor of Arts
African American Studies laude
Karolina rommel Bachelor of Arts English
magna laude Lindsey Ann Reb Bachelor
of Arts political science Christina and
Reichert Bachelor of Arts economics
Jonah Gabriel rank Bachelor of Arts
music Aisha and Rada Bachelor of Arts
sociology cassandra ray Quinn Bachelor
of Arts art history angel qui les
Bachelor of Arts political science
Kenneth Bruce pulled the second Bachelor
of Arts economics mathematics
Anuj Devendra Prasad Bachelor of Arts
biological sciences with a concentration
in psychology leo bo tape a bonito
bachelor of science chemistry
bersama T Paul bachelor of science
astronomy
Emily Shana passer Bachelor of Arts
political science
gu and park Bachelor of Arts economics
mathematics magna laude
Henry Park Bachelor of Arts East Asian
Studies
Dorian Molina bachelor of arts history
laude mica Emanuel Miller Bachelor
of Arts history Mohammed you see a
Parata Bachelor of Arts mathematics
statistics Tobias Eric panco Bachelor of
Arts economics and political science
magna laude a chalice Dane Barcroft
Paul von bachelor science earth science
Sarah Regina
Alton Bachelor of Arts English political
science concentration Kesley Erin Oleson
Bachelor of Arts Urban Studies Michael
Allen O'Toole Bachelor of Arts economics
philosophy Sean Jeremy O'Keefe Bachelor
of Arts economics political science
Victoria summer north bachelor of
science neuroscience and behavior
concentration mathematics summa
laude Phi Beta Kappa
Kevin Francis Nolan jr. Bachelor of Arts
economic statistics vaccine anurag a
Bachelor of Arts political science
ursini Bachelor of Arts economics
laude Kelvin on Geelong Bachelor of Arts
political science Cabo Bachelor of
Science applied mathematics
tamar sackter newman bachelor of arts
history laude Leslie McCracken
Bachelor of Arts English and comparative
literature
Brian Christopher Norman Korman Bachelor
of Arts political science concentration
in history summa laude Phi Beta
Kappa Isis Palomo Bachelor of Arts
classics summa laude a Phi Beta
Kappa
Peter coat
sir of science physics Jonathan
Nathaniel Newman Bachelor of Arts
English
Ryan Oliver lentejas Natividad Bachelor
of Arts anthropology kymo zhesan
Bachelor of Arts English concentration
in philosophy magna laude molly
Taryn Morgan Bachelor of Arts creative
writing in psychology magna laude
fillory faith more Bachelor of Arts
English concentration in Hispanic
studies laude christopher ryan more
Bachelor of Arts American Studies Matt
Moline Bachelor of Arts economics
philosophy
Diana Rose Mitchell Bachelor of Arts
anthropology Joshua David Middleton
Bachelor of Arts history Jonah Jacob
Meyerhoff Bachelor of Arts psychology
laude Russell bender Minkus bachelor
of arts history concentration in
sociology Lev Mendez Bachelor of Arts
English magna laude a Phi Beta Kappa
William Melendez Bachelor of Arts
philosophy Tomomi Matsui she Bachelor of
Arts East Asian Studies magna laude
a Dewayne Sean Johnson Bachelor of Arts
religion Kenya entry ah go Bachelor of
Arts political science Christopher John
Matthews Bachelor of Arts political
science Serena
Tamar Master Bachelor of Arts political
science laude Suzanne Michelle Mason
Bachelor of Arts English Michelle Lynn
Martel
Bachelor of Arts creative writing Justin
James Malloy Bachelor of Arts economic
statistics magna laude Evan
Christopher Madeo Bachelor of Arts
political science magna laude
katherine anne Madeo bachelor
Bart's anthropology magna laude a
Joe DiMaggio of arts psychology a Lisa
Marie McCabe Bachelor of Arts film
studies de white Colin McAllister
bachelor of science computer science
Olivia made a Lynn Bachelor of Arts
anthropology summa laude summer
Elise Lindsey Bachelor of Arts political
science magna laude a Phi Beta Kappa
zenlea Bachelor of Arts mathematics
magna laude Vera sloth kiss Levitt
Bachelor of Arts sociology laude
Elon P Feingold Bachelor of Arts
political science laude
Henry Faulkner Bachelor of Arts religion
tami-lynn learner Bachelor of Arts
political science Lee Ron Lerman
Bachelor of Arts economics political
science law and Lee Bachelor of Arts
psychology Julia ji-hyun leave Bachelor
of Arts Hispanic studies zachary erin
leb wohl Bachelor of Arts economics
Margo LaRoche Bachelor of Arts economics
mathematics amore LaRoche Bachelor of
Arts political science and sociology
laude jennifer michelle Latham Bachelor
of Arts architecture
Kate Larkin Bachelor of Arts philosophy
Peter Michael Lang Bachelor of Arts
English page Caldwell Lampkin Bachelor
of Arts economics political science
Kiley Wayne Lambert Bachelor of Arts
history and Middle East Asian languages
and cultures magna laude
Alfred Lam Bachelor of Arts psychology
laude a mark Quan Bachelor of Arts
history David Eddy Bachelor of Arts
psychology magna laude
melody are deckle Bachelor of Arts
psychology and sociology magna laude
Alexis Paige Kushner Bachelor of Arts
economics the winch Ian qo Bachelor of
Arts economics and mathematics
Avraham Jana Carosa herring Bachelor of
Arts Middle East and Asian languages and
cultures magna laude
Tali L amour Kovacs bachelor of arts
history laude Johanna
Elizabeth qu Soviets Bachelor of Arts
psychology Sarah Sewell kiku Bachelor of
Arts creative writing magna laude a
Frederick Linder volkens Lee Bachelor of
Arts economics laude a Mary Kim
Bachelor of Arts German literature and
culture magna laude a BB Khan
Bachelor of Arts political science Eve
Rosalind Keller bachelor of arts history
magna laude rachel page Katz
Bachelor of Arts art history laude
Yusuf shadi Khurram Bachelor of Arts
economics Scott Daniel Jurkowski
Bachelor of Arts political science high
eun-joo Bachelor of Arts East Asian
Studies
Benjamin Robert Bruno Bachelor of Arts
sociology summa laude a Phi Beta
Kappa Garrett J Blair Bachelor of Arts
Theater Arts summa laude a Phi Beta
Kappa
Patrick Ward Johnson bachelor of arts
history hosu Monica Jiang Bachelor of
Arts economics mathematics Marie
Nicolette Janeway bachelor of science
earth science
Nina prici Ippolito Bachelor of Arts
political science christina marie hughes
bachelor of arts psychology magna
laude daniel Holstein Bachelor of Arts
economics in history laude
Glenn Richard Hills Bachelor of Arts
creative writing Larissa
Kristen Higgins Bachelor of Arts
psychology concentration in political
science magna laude emily Letourneau
hayden bachelor of arts philosophy
concentration pre medical sciences
Thaddeus Denning Harvey Bachelor of Arts
Theater Arts Edward yuen-han Bachelor of
Arts biological sciences yo of Beau
Geste Goodman Bachelor of Arts African
Studies Ridley G Gunderson Bachelor of
Arts economics Paul Orion Grossman
Bachelor of Arts creative writing and
Quinet Lynnae berry Bachelor of Arts
sociology Juan Carlos Arenado Bachelor
of Arts English
David Karl Greenfield Bachelor of Arts
economics
Itamar Goldstein bachelor of science
neuroscience and behavior magna
laude
Timothy Richard Gable Bachelor of Arts
mathematics Ruth Shira glass Bachelor of
Arts psychology Adam le Jin dia Bachelor
of Arts religion Shirley Furman Bachelor
of Arts anthropology and film studies
Rea Yehuda Friedman Bachelor of Arts
biological sciences magna laude
jennifer madeline Fraser Bachelor of
Arts history and theory of architecture
and history brianna Lee Fraser Bachelor
of Arts psychology magna laude
ashley elizabeth flood bachelor of arts
economics concentration in anthropology
laude
Lisa fish and fell bachelor of science
physics Maria del Carmen Ferreira
Bachelor of Arts art history and French
Lauren F Feinberg Bachelor of Arts art
history magna laude chelsea ray
affair Bank Bachelor of Arts
anthropology with a concentration in
human right
laude Amira Yahya alchool ad
Bachelor of Arts English with a
concentration in philosophy Kylie Kylie
Patricia Spooner Bachelor of Arts Urban
Studies
Pamela Gayle Faber Bachelor of Arts
political science magna laude a Phi
Beta Kappa Davide Fabien Bachelor of
Arts film studies laude a Jane is so
I berola
a Bachelor of Arts English Hannah Aviva
Elkin bachelor of arts history laude
Helene Mara
Eisenstein Bachelor of Arts creative
writing laude Nash D Dunlop Bachelor
of Arts comparative ethnic studies
Erin L Duffy Bachelor of Arts economics
with a concentration in psychology magna
laude maritza
arlene dono Bachelor of Arts economics
political science
Sasha Catherine ma Husky Bachelor of
Arts psychology magna laude
Elizabeth Diaz Bachelor of Arts
anthropology with a concentration in
Hispanic studies magna laude a Phi
Beta Kappa
Casey JD as Bachelor of Arts sociology
Alicia Deena de Ludi Bachelor of Arts
Middle East and Asian languages and
cultures manisa Saldana dawood Bachelor
of Arts psychology 'no Mima amina amend
a Bachelor of Arts biological sciences
magna laude Alfred Davis Bachelor of
Arts history say Healy Dada Bachelor of
Arts economics concentration in art
history Ryan Christopher damron Bachelor
of Arts Middle East and Asian languages
and culture summa laude a Phi Beta
Kappa Jessie Rose Cuthbert pain Bachelor
of Arts urban studies Cara Michelle
Crownover
Bachelor of Arts English laude
jessica nicole collins bachelor
Bart's anthropology Yvonne Cristina Cole
Bank Bachelor of Science environmental
sciences
Evelyn casado Bachelor of Arts political
science magna laude
Jonathan Matthew koi Co Bachelor of Arts
sociology vitani al Eliezer Cohen
Bachelor of Arts history
Caitlin Corinne Cohen Bachelor of Arts
art history with a concentration in
psychology Gregory Allen pluot Bachelor
of Arts American Studies laude
yes Mullins Carlina Davis Bachelor of
Arts sociology Jenny Chang Bachelor of
Arts economics song joy Bachelor of Arts
economics Charles Norman cat anak
bachelor of science computer science
doing Camargo bachelor of science
computer science Eileen and Callaghan
Gallagher Bachelor of Arts urban studies
William Marion bunch Bachelor of Arts
creative writing concentration in
education laude Shayla bull trend
echeverria bachelor of arts literature
writing Laura Lambert Darby Brown
Bachelor of Science evolutionary biology
of the human species
Hilary Rachel Brown Bachelor of Arts
Classical Studies laude Suzette
Breitbart
Bachelor of Arts film studies benjamin
heart says lack Bachelor of Arts history
and political science
Robert Chow Bachelor of Arts psychology
Barbara Bartley boys Bachelor of Arts
history Michael Steven Bonin Bachelor of
Arts biological sciences magna laude
a Phi Beta Kappa KC Mathieu black
Bachelor of Arts creative writing magna
laude elizabeth rebecca Bergamo
Bachelor of Arts
English laude michael Berta's
Bachelor of Arts political science
virtus Bala Bachelor of Arts economics
philosophy Denis Irene of oleo Bachelor
of Arts English and sociology magna
laude Janish our Bachelor of Arts
economics magna laude
Ruth st Ruth Esther Ashkenazi Bachelor
of Arts history
Talal nadir Ansari Bachelor of Arts
political science Abiola economy
Bachelor of Arts economics political
science Laurel Ann Kayla Ackerson
Bachelor of Arts Middle East and Asian
languages and culture with a
concentration in sociology
Madalyn Murray Benoit the TiVo Bachelor
of Arts sociology Joshua Ben Bachelor of
Arts Hispanic studies with a
concentration in linguistics magna
laude tatiana belabor dov' Bachelor of
Arts economics jennifer michelle abrams
Bachelor of Arts sociology Paul Roberts
Stegman Bachelor of Arts ancient studies
laude Larisa illinichna Goosen goose
on the Cova bachelor of arts russian
literature and culture magna laude
Tracy Jean Harford Bachelor of Arts
anthropology Damian Peter van der puddin
Bachelor of Arts psychology shanshu
Bachelor of Arts political science Eric
Lee Beckman Bachelor of Arts economics
Shalom onuma and Bachelor of Arts
economics mathematics laude laura
and Bandler Bachelor of Arts political
science John Shea sang Bachelor of
Science biochemistry Lynne Charlene Dao
Bachelor of Arts history Sarah Don King
best Bachelor of Arts Hispanic studies
magna laude
Alexander cameltoe Frandsen Bachelor of
Arts economics my eco Arabic Ariza Basu
Sato Bachelor of Arts psychology
well the class of 2010 please rise
president Bollinger Provost eel
executive vice president Dirk's Dean on
distinguished faculty TS alumni
cherished friends and family members
I am honored and delighted to present to
you the general studies class of 2010
see this congratulations to the
graduates your family's loved ones and
friends you embody in a unique and
compelling way the mission and vision of
GS and Columbia I hope you will stay
involved with your Columbia family for
many years to come I invite you all to
continue the celebration at the class d
reception to be held on the lawn
directly to your left I ask our guests
to remain seated while the president's
party and the candidates file out will
the candidates please stand
study
down by the riverside how about a real
sir or later
you